my name is Superman do 10 and the chief
executive of mighty movies a TV
production company in Zimbabwe I think
that the 2010 world cup will not only
benefit South Africa I think would you
benefit the region but much of the
economic benefits will be felt in South
Africa certainly because most of the
people will be coming for the world cup
will be coming to visit South Africa
some may visit some regional countries
Zimbabwe Zambia Malawi in other
countries that have fantastic tourist
attractions in the region but what is
important also is that the focus on
Africa will help change the image of
Africa across the world because there is
a negative image about Africa much of it
is perception is actually not a reality
but having the world media which is
coming to cover the football and the
whole lot of people from after the
African continent will see for
themselves that Africa is not what is
perceived out there that Africa is far
much ahead than what they actually think
it is in terms of a development in terms
of opportunity and in terms of going
forward thank you